.
WE ARE NOT COMPLAINING HERE.
WE ARE NOT COMPLAINING.
MINNESOTA GOVERNOR TIM WALZ
SPOKE WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN
YESTERDAY AND HE JOINS US NOW.
GOVERNOR, GOOD MORNING.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, GAYLE.
>> I'M REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR SAT DOWN HE
SAID IT'S A REALLY GOOD MORNING,
I CAN LOOK AROUND, THERE ARE NO
BROKEN WINDOWS.
I TALKED TO YOU THE NIGHT BEFORE
THAT I COULDN'T SLEEP.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT YOU MUST
HAVE BEEN FEELING AS YOU WERE
WAITING.
>> MINNESOTANS ARE BREATHING A
SIGH OF RELIEF.
THAT WHITE HOT SPOTLIGHT THAT'S
BEEN ON US SINCE WE AND THE
WORLD WATCHED GEORGE FREUD BEING
MURDERED FEELS DIFFERENT TODAY.
NOW WE'RE THE STATE THAT
CONVICTED GEORGE FLOYD'S
MURDERER.
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM FOLKS IS
NOW LET'S START THE HARD WORK.
>> I WANT TO GET TO THE HARD
WORK IN JUST A SECOND, BUT DID
YOU THINK THAT IT COULD GO THREE
TO THREE?
DID YOU THINK THAT?
>> WELL, WHAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS, AND I
WANT TO -- YES, BECAUSE KEITH
ELLISON IS AN AMAZING ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND HAD AN AMAZING TEAM.
>> THE TEAM HE PUT TOGETHER WAS
OUTSTANDING.
>> AND THE COURAGE OF THOSE
WITNESSES, INCLUDING CHILDREN
WHO HAD THE COURAGE TO SIT ON
THAT STAND AFTER VIDEOTAPING, I
THOUGHT THE CASE WAS SOLID.
I KEEP SILENT TO NOT -- BUT
EVERYTHING IN MY HEART SAID THEY
WERE GOING TO GET THE
CONVICTION.
THEN I WOULD TALK TO BLACK
MINNESOTANS WHO SAY WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT, IT NEVER WORKS
THAT WAY.
I THINK THAT JUST HIGHLIGHTS
WHERE THAT GAP IS AND HOW BIG IT
IS.
>> YOU DID SEE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HOW WHITE PEOPLE SAW IT
AND BLACK PEOPLE SAW THE
VERDICT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE WAS NOT A BLACK PERSON
THAT I TALKED TO THAT HAD ANY
COMFORT.
THEY ACKNOWLEDGED THIS WAS AN
AMAZING PROSECUTION.
THE EVIDENCE WAS OVERWHELMING.
HE MURDERED GEORGE FLOYD ON THAT
STREET LAST MAY.
BUT THEY SAID THIS HAS HAPPENED
TIME AND TIME AGAIN AND IT
DOESN'T WORK.
AND SO I THINK THAT SENSE AS
THEY SEE IT TODAY, I THINK THIS
IS THE SENSE OF -- WE'RE
CELEBRATING SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SO CLEAR CUT
AND NORMAL BUT IT'S NOT FOR
BLACK MINNESOTANS AND BLACK
AMERICANS.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE HARD
WORK, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
I TALKED TO TWO OF YOUR
COUNCILMEN YESTERDAY THAT SAID
BASICALLY NOTHING HAS CHANGED IN
TERMS OF POLICING, IN TERMS OF
HOW THINGS ARE HANDLED IN THIS
STATE.
CONSIDERING HOW GEORGE FLOYD WAS
MURDERED, NOTHING HAS CHANGED IN
THE YEAR.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> I THINK THEY'RE RIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S THE FEELING THAT
MUCH MORE HAS TO BE DONE.
WE CAME TOGETHER IN JULY IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THAT AND IN A
DIVIDED LEGISLATURE WE FOUND
BIPARTISAN -- IT'S NOT A BIG
LIFT TO SAY WE SHOULD BAN
CHOKEHOLDS BUT THERE WERE SO
MANY ACTIVISTS SAYING THAT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE MENTAL
HEALTH FOLKS ARE RESPONDING TO
THESE.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE TRAFFIC
STOPS ARE NOT REASONS TO ARREST
FOLKS AND LEAD TO THESE
CONFRONTATIONS THAT YOU SEE.
NOW IS THAT MOMENT.
THIS WHITE-HOT SPOTLIGHT THAT'S
BEEN ON MINNESOTA CAN'T LEAVE
NOW.
MY FEAR IS EVERYBODY PACKS UP
AND WE THINK WE'VE GOT THIS.
AS I'VE BEEN SAYING, THIS IS THE
FLOOR.
THIS IS THE VERY BASIC FLOOR OF
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE.
BUT WHAT LED TO THAT HAPPENING
ON 38th AND CHICAGO WHERE ALL
THE THINGS WE NEED TO CHANGE.
I'M A SCHOOLTEACHER.
MY WIFE AND I ARE SCHOOLTEACHER.
THE EDUCATION INEQUITIES.
WE DO WELL FOR WHITE CHILDREN
BUT NOT BLACK CHILDREN.
LET'S MAKE SURE HOMEOWNERSHIP
STARTS TO BRING UP BLACK
MINNESOTANS.
>> BUT THEY WOULD SAY YOU'RE
SITTING IN THE BIG BOY CHAIR, DO
SOMETHING.
>> ONE OF THE POWERS OF THE
GOVERNOR AND THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH IS TO THE LEGISLATION.
I HAVE THE ONLY DIVIDED
LEGISLATURE IN THE COUNTRY WHERE
ONE IS DEMOCRAT AND ONE IS THE
SENATE.
WE HAVE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
REACHING TOO FAR OR PUTTING
PEOPLE IN A POSITION WHERE THEY
FEEL THAT'S THE THREAT, THIS
AFTERNOON I'LL BE TALKING WITH
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
HOLDER AND WE NEED TO PUT THINGS
IN PLACE THAT ASK US TO HAVE
THOSE HARD LOOKS, ASK US HOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE MEDIA,
HOW WE'RE DOING POLICING AND
HAVE A STATEWIDE STANDARD.
WE HAVE A POST BOARD, PUT IN
SOME STANDARDS.
>> PEOPLE SAY YOU CERTAINLY
ACKNOWLEDGED THE DISCREPANCY
WITH BLACK PEOPLE.
TOO MANY BLACK PEOPLE LOST AND
CONTINUE TO LOSE THEIR LIVES AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU SAID THAT.
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR SAID
MINNESOTA IS NOT A PLACE WHERE
IT IS SAFE TO BE BLACK.
I THINK PEOPLE OF COLOR
LISTENING TO THAT ARE GOING
WHAT?
THAT'S NOT VERY COMFORTING OR
WELCOMING.
>> NO, NO, AND IT NEEDS TO BE.
I THINK THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AS A WOMAN OF COLOR, INDIGENOUS
WOMAN, THAT'S HER LIFE LIVED
EXPERIENCES.
MINE AS A WHITE MAN IS DIFFERENT
BUT IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY TO
BRIDGE THIS GAP.
IT'S NOT BLACK PEOPLE WHO DON'T
SEE IT, IT'